i think it's great that you guys are
actually publicly having the
conversation i think that's a positive
that lafleur is willing to talk about it
you are and that means it's going in the
right direction i know a lot of people
thought it was a negative and i just
didn't see it that way
another negative about having a lot of
experience being able to do things other
quarterbacks just can't do that yeah
right right or haven't done right
right you have to put go ahead okay i
gotta eagle come on impress us one more
time
chris sims and aaron rodgers in tahoe a
couple of years ago too short of a force
and we could have completed that for
some miles not that aaron rodgers would
have wanted me to be part of that for
some but that would have been fun that
would have made it interesting that
would have made it spicy all right
here's our draft for today the ultimate
nfl-related foursomes any nfl figure
past present even future if you choose
to do so
us
plus three others go you're up first
okay uh my first is bruce arians and i
will tell you why because i am a very
bad golfer it's just not who are the
other two who are the other two he can't
just be brucerians who are the other two
oh wait i'm going all all three of them
okay all right yes
uh give me peyton manning and then jerry
rice
so those are my three because bruce
arians is the kind of golfer that would
make sure that everybody has a drink in
their hand if they don't have a club in
their hands and that's my kind of golf
peyton manning we hear stories about the
rookie year with bruce arians and peyton
manning that sounds very interesting to
me jerry rice he's supposed to be a very
good golfer so he would probably hear
peyton would be the best of uh the four
of us so and also he's the best receiver
of all time so who wouldn't want to golf
with him right those are those are my
guys
oh they got the cigars too i would
definitely want to be part of that
foursome peter and i were talking
earlier today about the chicago bears
and richard dents classic line that they
won a super bowl because of mike ditka
and they won a super bowl and only a
super bowl because of mike ditka i would
want mike ditka
jim mcmahon buddy ryan and just just
hang out and just see how it all played
out and just kind of be there i don't
know that i'd survive the 18 holes i'd
keep my mouth shut and my ears and eyes
open and that would be a raucous four or
five hours or longer on the golf course
miles
so you want to have all right we want to
have the same kind of time on the golf
course it's not really about the golf
it's more about the company and the
camaraderie or lack thereof and all the
different stories that would come out
i completely misunderstood the
assignment and i'll take the fall for it
i didn't realize it was three others one
at a time i thought we were coming up
with multiple foursomes i got a list of
a bunch of different foursomes miles let
me run some of these by you we had aaron
rodgers on earlier with with chris sims
i would want to go
aaron rodgers jordan love mark murphy
the mad scientist who's cooked up this
awkward situation in green bay wouldn't
that be fun to be around those guys for
four or five hours i might i might
substitute mark murphy for matt lafleur
because you have to go into all of the
different nuances probably with him and
then with the two quarterbacks i think
that would be fun and also i've met matt
with fleur before and we worked together
on 2017 with the rams so i guess that's
a perfect well matt lafleur malloy floor
is great and and none of this is is his
doing i don't believe the jordan was not
his pick
yeah yeah well but but i'd want the guy
there who made the call who seems to be
thinking we've got protection against
aaron rodgers slipping and we've also
got the presence of a guy that's going
to piss him off just enough that he's
maybe going to be the mvp oh wait he was
the mvp in 2020 maybe he's still pissed
off enough that'll be the mvp in 2021
but you know when you're around people
who know each other and you can just
kind of observe and you see how they
interact and the body language you can't
avoid awkward for five hours if there's
any awkward at all it's going to come
out in the interpersonal relationships
on the golf course isn't it who's gonna
who's gonna bust the other guy's chops
what who are they gonna make fun of
right what are they gonna do when the
guy's getting ready to tee off you know
i i just think that by the time you get
to the 18th hole
you will know a lot about how each of
those three individuals actually feels
about why are you laughing i think we
should golf
i think i think i'll learn a lot about
you and you'll learn a lot about me over
the nine hours it will be out there
because that's how long it would take me
to whole out 18 times you you
you would probably hate uh golfing with
me i would hate golfing with myself
because i'm terrible at it okay let me
run one other three somebody because i
got i got another one that we could do
how about andy reid patrick mahomes and
travis kelsey i just want to hear
stories about their about the 2019
season and then one of them could bring
us some barbecue because i think andy
reid would have the connection from q39
right or arthur bryant's down there in
kansas city and we would have a great
time just eating all day and maybe
swinging some clubs too
i would swap out andy reed
for post malone because of the story
that was told about kelsey mahomes and
malone
before his concert
and they got drunk off their ass
so i'm gonna win at golf and i'm gonna
take all their money that's my ideal
force i'm so sorry andy you can stay in
the clubhouse and eat hamburgers i want
post malone out there plus a fully
stocked beer cart because those three
guys are gonna get blitzed and i'm gonna
win with a 125. that's a pretty good
idea um i don't mind that i post malone
can maybe play us a couple songs i'll
stay
oh uh wow
circles know any of those mike
i don't know any of his songs i just
know he is my son my son used to be a
big post malone fan but then
but then i i don't know like the the
taste change and post malone's kind of
outdated now so uh sorry pose malone
wasn't there a song
song that was like top 40 i i don't i i
i get very depressed i get very
depressed
now when i realize how completely out of
touch i am when it comes to pop culture
that of that kind
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports